SPEAKER: To get started with
the Speech API for Node.js,
you'll need a GCP project, which
you can set up in the console.
Enable the Speech
API for that project,
then, create a service account
and download the private key
as Jason.
You're going to use
these credentials
to access Google Cloud APIs, so
keep this file secure and out
of your code and public repos.
To access the credential
securely from your project,
go to the terminal and set
an environment variable
to the path of your
service account.
Now, prepare your environment
Node.js development.
Install the client library.
If you use Cloud
Shell on the console,
you can skip this step, since
the required dependencies
are already included.
For this example, you
will need some audio which
contains speech to transcribe.
There's a sample
audio you can download
linked in the notes below.
Move your audio sample to the
project in a resources folder,
and change the name
of the file to make
a generic for example purposes.
Now, you don't actually have to
change the name of your file,
but just remember to
write it correctly
when prompted to write
the file name to the code.
Make a new project file
or open an existing file.
Open the Google Cloud client
library and the file system
module.
Start with an async
function called main,
then instantiate
a speech client.
Provide the file name
of the audio file
you want to transcribe,
then use file system to read
the local audio file and
convert it to Base64 encoding.
Create a document called
audio with a field called
content, set to that
base64 string of the audio.
Provide some details
about configuration
in an object called config.
You must include the
type of encoding,
the sample rate in
Hertz, and the language
of the speech in the audio, but
there are also optional fields.
You can find out more about
those fields in the API
documentation link below.
Instantiate an object
called request,
which is made up of the
audio and config objects.
Call recognize, passing
the request object.
This returns a
promise that resolves
to contain the result at zero
or more sequential speech
recognition result messages.
Each speech recognition
result has a property
called alternatives, which may
contain one or more recognition
hypotheses.
An alternative has three
properties, transcript,
confidence and words.
Transcript is a string
representing the words
that the user spoke.
Confidence is a number
between 0.0 and 1.0,
where a higher number
indicates an estimated greater
likelihood that the
recognized words are correct.
Words is an array of
word info objects.
I won't talk more
about word info,
since it goes beyond the
scope of this quick start.
But if you're curious,
check out the API reference
to find out more.
To print out the transcription,
get the first alternative
from each result, then join
them in a single string.
Log that transcription.
Run the main function
and include a catch block
to handle any errors.
Save your file and run the code.
If everything
worked properly, you
should see the
transcription of the text.
If not, take a look back at
the code for any syntax errors.
Congratulations.
You've just sent your
first request to the Speech
to Text API.
To find out more about
the client libraries
or consult speech basics, check
out the Cloud documentation.